here's something you should know the
United States is conducting 3,500
military missions per year in Africa
that's around 10 missions a day but if
you want to know why we're there you
have to travel back to the time before
the so-called war on terror began our
war on terror begins with al-qaeda but
it does not end there
before President Ronald Reagan described
Muammar Gaddafi as Mad Dog of the Middle
East has a goal of a world revolution
Muslim fundamentalist revolution back to
the Cold War era when the discovery of
oil reserves off Africa's coast drew the
United States attention that's where we
need to start to understand why the u.s.
is on a continent where it's supposedly
not at war and yet at least 36 US
soldiers have died there since 2001
you're at center Graham there he didn't
know we had a thousand troops in Nazaire
did you all right no I did not hey fam
I'm a Mayan this is a J plus and this
Sunday we're exploring the United States
military presence in Africa its impact
and how it may actually be fueling the
ever expanding war on terror
[Music]
Africa has 54 United Nations recognized
countries and whether you realize it or
not the United States presence in this
year isn't an outlier let me show you
the dozens of pins you're seeing right
now are all locations where the United
States has some sort of presence each
pin represents a US military training
advisory our tactical deployment
partnership or base and according to
Nick Turse a fellow at the nation
Institute the number of pins were seen
demonstrates a huge increase from
previous years on any given day
generally there are somewhere between
6,000 and 8,000 US troops scattered
across as many as 49 countries
he says the United States Africa Command
or AFRICOM for short made a 2,000
percent increase in the amount of
missions and exercises over the course
of just one year if you're wondering how
Africans feel about the US on the
continent don't worry we'll get to that
a little later but right now you need to
know AFRICOM is leading the United
States efforts in Africa we reached out
to them and in an email response to aj+
AFRICOM sent its goal in Africa is to
work with partners to disrupt and
neutralize transnational threats protect
US personnel and facilities prevent and
mitigate conflict and build defense
capability and capacity in order to
promote regional stability and
prosperity well that's not only a
mouthful but it's also an extensive
to-do list and Terce says AFRICOM has
strayed pretty far from its original
humanitarian mission it wasn't really
going to be a combatant command at all
it was more concerned with humanitarian
operations as we've seen in me share
Somalia Libya there's much more going on
so why is the United States really in
Africa Comfort ero the Africa Director
at the International Crisis Group says
the United States presence in Africa is
really a search for beneficial
partnerships the US has had a long
tradition of providing military
assistance training to a number of key
African states that it sees as important
allies I mean
so national interest is the United
States agenda the same as the local
citizens and communities each trying to
partner with some don't think so if you
ask local communities local seed again
as sort of a new form of neocolonialism
a new form of sort of an extra sort of
security blanket for the central
government aro says local critics view
intervention by countries like the
United States and France as unhelpful
because Western nations support central
governments that the critics of this
light remember that because we're going
to come back to it but before we go
deeper we need to break down the
overarching theme in the United States
presence in Africa and it's something
you've heard a lot about in the last 20
years combating terrorism the idea of
Africa being at the forefront of
terrorism prevention isn't some
post-september 11 revelation for the
u.s. because before terrorism there was
oil Africa really cost the US military's
eye when huge oil reserves were
discovered in the Gulf of Guinea in the
1960s the US which already had global
footprints was largely absent in Africa
at the time Africa became sort of the
stomping ground and sort of proxy
conflicts and tensions global tensions
between Russia and and China but the
United States presence in Africa isn't
only link to the continents natural
resources in the late 1990s the world
saw a deadly terrorist attacks in Africa
and security concerns became a part of
an international narrative the 1998 car
bombing attacks against US embassies in
Kenya and Tanzania were linked to
al-qaeda and Osama bin Laden and the
u.s. started paying attention there was
an idea that places that were weak or
fragile states on governed spaces these
were areas that were going to be ripe
for terrorist infiltration the United
States pumped in you know hundreds of
millions of dollars in counterterrorism
funding after the September 11th attacks
the u.s. returned to the Horn of Africa
to set up its first military base in
Djibouti
but tur says the US operations were ad
hoc was very haphazard affair there were
training missions but they were
conducted
they're different authorities under
different combatant commands AFRICOM has
centralized everything that's going on
in the continent the United States one
in AFRICOM to be based on the continent
in Mali but there was opposition
remember who Regan called a mad dog well
the same Libyan leader didn't want
Africa in Africa so its HQ was set up in
Germany but it was AFRICOM that started
the intervention in Libya in 2011 that
eventually toppled Gaddafi
so today Africa comms presence is felt
all over Africa while AFRICOM sees
itself as an agent against security
threats
ters believes the united states
intervention actually may be
exacerbating the region's risk over the
time that the united states has poured
in counterterrorism funding sent
trainers to the continent made this a
priority there's been a growth of
somewhere around 50 terrorist groups or
illicit militant groups as as they're
called operating in Africa so they've
gone from zero to 50 the United States
current strategy focuses on building
capacity and capabilities of partner
countries and their militaries it's
often giving those nations large tons of
money and equipment and yet if the goal
is to create stability then the US isn't
always hitting the mark Church says the
US has trained and supported militaries
and countries like Burkina Faso Chad new
share Mali and Mauritania only to have
the militaries of those countries become
more powerful than the governments
themselves Mali is a striking example in
2013 rebels were on the verge of taking
over the whole country France intervened
backed by the US and African allies but
what you may not know is that the u.s.
had already been supporting molly's
military for years and it was a US
military trained Malayan Army captain
named a Medusa no go who took over the
country in a coup in 2012 and guess what
he was even more ineffective at driving
back the rebels than the existing
government Mali has been in a state of
an intractable insurgency you have what
might have been the best intentions but
instead US operations in the region
completely destabilized Mali but here's
the really unnerving fact the rebels got
their weapons from the US and other
Western powers who were aiding them in
Biya when they were trying to overthrow
Gaddafi those rebels took the very same
weapons back with them into northern
Mali southern Algeria Libya and Nazir
and in some cases even use them against
the US and European presence just so you
know this happened during President
Obama's watch and there's still another
major issue with the u.s. being in
Africa Africa may be supporting
militaries who have been accused of
gross human rights violations
for example the celac base in Cameroon
is integral to the USS footprint on the
continent but it was also the site of
illegal imprisonment and persistent
torture as Terrace reported there was
ongoing torture over a period of of
years on the space United States troops
were not implicated in the torture
itself but it seems almost inconceivable
that US troops on the base didn't know
what was going on in an email response
AFRICOM told us promoting human rights
is a key aspect to the assistance they
provide the added that the law doesn't
allow them or the State Department to
give aid to foreign military units that
violate people's human rights and
incidents like these have had a real
impact the u.s. presence in the
continent has galvanized local militants
they see the u.s. as occupying force
because of this United States doesn't
make any friends on the continent and
often makes itself many more enemies
than it actually eliminates in fact a
2017 UN report determined that combating
groups with these tactics makes it
easier for them to recruit people into
the same groups ero says the US and
foreign powers need more than a military
approach we're not saying that there is
no place for military intervention it's
necessary but it must be bound up by a
clear political strategy as well the
future of the United States in Africa is
dependent upon President Trump and so
far his policy has been to give military
generals and AFRICOM more leeway to
conduct lethal operations but isn't this
really something the public and Congress
should be debating we just spent a lot
of time talking about the United States
presence in Africa and maybe you're
wondering if it looks like a lot like
their presence in the Middle East tell
us what you think let us know what you
want us to cover next don't forget to
Like share and subscribe and I'll see
you next Sunday when we're back here
with another awesome video thanks so
much for
Jim